Arthur flex biggest joke might be the
one he pulled on you
Joker director Todd Phillips recently
made a few very interesting comments to
the Los Angeles Times about the final
scene of the movie comments that imply a
bizarre truth about the story being
presented in case that's not warning
enough be advised that major spoilers
for the Joker lie ahead Joaquin
Phoenix's Arthur is depicted early and
often as having a tenuous grip on
reality the film eventually lets on that
it's not always clear which events are
fantasy and which are reality not to the
audience and presumably not to Arthur at
the end
Arthur is seen with his psychiatrist in
Arkham state hospital after he has
apparently killed his mother incited a
riot shot Marie Franklin on live
television
and escaped from police custody with the
help of his clown masked followers as
the shrink attempts to question him
Arthur simply laughs telling her that
she wouldn't get the joke according to
Phillips it's this particular laugh that
might hold a clue about the true nature
of the story that just unfolded
he explained that laughs in that scene
is really the only time he laughs
genuinely there are different laughs in
the movie there is the laugh from
Arthur's affliction and then there is
his fake laugh when he's trying to be
one of the people which is my favorite
laugh but at the end when he's in the
room at Arkham state hospital that's his
only genuine laugh in the movie why is
that exactly well perhaps because in the
end the joke is on us the audience
philips has said that one of the main
influences on his film was The Killing
Joke the acclaimed 1988 graphic novel in
which the Joker says that if he must
have a past he quote prefers it to be
multiple choice the director made a
direct allusion to this dialogue in
suggesting that as many fans have
speculated Arthur Fleck might not
necessarily be who we think he is
Phillips said there are lots of ways you
could look at this movie you could look
at it and go this is just one of his
multiple choice stories none of it
happened I don't want to say what it is
but a lot of people I've shown it to
have said oh I get it he's just made up
a story the whole movie is the joke
this thing the sky in Arkham Asylum
concocted he might not even be the Joker
Phillips went on to state outright that
the man who will become Batman's nemesis
may simply be in the background
somewhere
watching all of these events play out he
said maybe Joaquin's character inspired
the Joker you don't really know his last
line in the movie is you wouldn't get it
there's a lot going on in there that's
interesting
Phoenix himself also explained that
Joker can be seen not so much as a
straightforward narrative but as a
series of suggestions during his own
conversation with The Times he said the
movie requires a certain amount of
participation from the audience it's up
to you how you want to interpret it and
experience it it's less you being kind
of presented with the facts then you
being presented with these possibilities
Phillips may have given the whole game
away however when he revealed that a
face-off with Batman would never be part
of his potential sequel to Joker saying
we would never do that no no we just
want to see where Arthur goes from there
do you see those two worlds merging
together anytime soon nope definitely
not taken together with Philips previous
remarks were left with a compelling
possibility that Arthur isn't really the
Joker at least not the Joker who goes
toe-to-toe with Batman his entire
rampage might have taken place entirely
in his head perhaps he told the story to
a fellow Arkham inmate who told it to
someone else who passed it along until
it was eventually heard by the man who
would become the true Clown Prince of
Crime for now we can't say for sure but
don't worry Phillips told Entertainment
Tonight that eventually they'll reveal
the truth one day I will say what we
think and we meant when we were writing
it check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about Joker are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one